the big story from here in Indianapolis
calimary measured out 5 foot 10 inches
and 1/8 207 pounds nine and a half
inches on the hand obviously everyone's
super excited about that that means he's
going to run over all right well you
know I don't think so
but it looks like he's not going to
perform any of the drills because when
you yeah so everyone's saying he's at
old Scouts and personnel people here
doesn't plan to throw he's not going to
do any of the drills he's gonna stand
around he's gonna do the medical and the
interviews plan to work out at Oklahoma
Pro Day March 13th I hate it
yes I ate it I don't like it that Deion
Deion by the way one of the most
electric if they could do Nana Monahan
football booth by the way I'm out I am
completely I love Deion Sanders I think
he's greatest athlete of all time he's
electric on a microphone and he he spews
good stuff on Instagram the other day he
released a video of him saying I wanted
to go to the combine to show everybody
what they had heard about me was right
or was true or something like that
anyone in their swagging or whatever I
feel like there should be more of that
but if it goes wrong for Kyler and he's
got some wide receiver that's running a
different route he's supposed to it
could look bad there's just too much
money in too many agents but I like to
see people perform yeah but all the
scouts and evaluators tell me that they
understand if the balls from a different
spot because it's a receiver they could
tell if the receiver did something wrong
or not they just want to see the ball
fly out of his hand that's what Baker
Mayfield did here last year everybody
wanted was talking about how Mayfield
live looked in a way that many scouts
who hadn't seen him play live or coaches
or evaluators you know but again I'm
biased I want to see him throw out there
on NFL Network let me ask you this
question Pat okay what if a punter came
to the combine oh yeah I'm refused to
punt
would be hilarious and say I choose - I
choose to get measured medical I do the
medical I'll do your Wonderlic let's
meet in the interview room but I will
not punt
I will punt on my pro day well I don't
think it's possible strictly because
it's a new ball right so like it's there
something you have to really yeah I
don't know I do not I do know I don't
think punters would do it I do not like
your jugs gun that's snapping the ball
at me I'm not I want my own jugs gun
I will not punt it but also the thing
that I was not invited to combine you're
not now from what I've been told though
the balls are brand new as well which if
a brand new ball ends up in a game for
me I'm probably yelling at the refs so I
could very much understand getting up
and being like I'm not doing this what
does it take to be a punter invited the
combine 45 yards 50 yards all-time
leading scorer in and West Virginia
history just four ballgames missed a
couple kicks got a couple I was actually
told at the Senior Bowl yeah by the
Cincinnati Bengals special teams coach
is a friend of mine now his name's
Darren he wears advisors got great hair
you see him on the sideline does a lot
action he's a good guy at the scene of
all I was kicking field goals
I was the South's kicker yeah and they
were coaching the North squad so we only
had one day to meet with them and he was
like so what are you gonna do in the NFL
are you gonna be a kicker punter or
whatever I was like I don't know I think
I can do both and he was like nobody can
do both you're at the Senior Bowl to be
a kicker if I were you I've never point
a football again I was like mom man you
got it I'm like okay an NFL coach told
me not to do it so I just focused on
kicking mm-hmm literally until Bill
Polian Scout came out had me kick Phil
blows and I was a keep on a couple I was
like yeah so I punted a couple and then
boom here we go and then we played them
in pre-season my rookie year okay and
I'm the punter now for the Colts and oh
I did a nice Vince McMahon strut right
over never put a ball good huh that's a
good idea he said I did not think this
was gonna happen
did you punt at West Virginia - yeah but
we were rugby punters so I would catch
the ball just run to my right and just
stuff yeah well all colleges do it now
that we we're doing it back in the day
and you don't you're cutting yeah
trailblazer really what else you guys
okay Antonio Brown if it's if it's a day
that ends and why it's more Antonio
Brown knows he sat down Jeff Darlington
Wow
talking so the the trade talks must not
be going to his liking so so the teaser
clip that Jeff had tweeted out yeah he
addressed ben roethlisberger
or Kevin Cole Burt's fifty two kids
comment about then pretty much
explaining what I already had told
everyone he just confirmed it and I
didn't go about it in a bad way and said
I said it cuz I know fans my fans want
to hear from me obviously I know there's
some cultural issues and some you know I
mean issues that was already at hand you
know I already knew but I couldn't
really say that because I out of respect
for the organization and for the members
I work with I don't want to put them in
an uncomfortable position what what
ideally grown man is called another
grown man a kid fifty two kids like you
don't have no respect for these guys
like these the guys that go to work for
you and that's what I'm telling you guys
that that's what that's my issue I'm
saying it's all about respect
I mean Kolbert said yesterday that he
referred to fifty two kids that's how he
talks about them is what he said and he
will always say what he says in public
what he says behind closed doors is that
he referred to them as kids because none
of them n in the Superbowl compared to
the grown-ass man Ben Roethlisberger who
has hey grown-ass man Ben Roethlisberger
also gets on the radio show on Tuesdays
and throws teammates under the bus
publicly which is a very interesting
move Ben Roethlisberger elite
quarterback not a lead off the field I
think weekend that's not really
debatable Antonio Brown doing this
interview though from his mega-mansion
which is what the video have you seen a
video yeah yeah it looked very saddam
bunker like that man that was incredible
I mean there was golden it was everyone
in Lobby and they were sitting the two
inches away from each other to square
right Jeff Darlington is staring Antonio
Brown that mustache face to face in the
middle of this Lobby that's at least ten
thousand square feet I can't wait to see
the whole video
Antonio Brown though is gonna end up on
a team make a lot of money and probably
be in a Pro Bowl for the next five years
somewhere but what did you make of the
Packers what do you I mean just hearing
though knowing what Packers that
wouldn't be bad obviously I think he's a
good friend all seriousness though I
mean he has brought to light something
about Ben but
he's he's a guy who didn't show on week
17 with the season on well he got a lot
of beef with that decision - by the way
I read he was not happy he did not play
he I mean if you look at that locker
room it has been a reality show there
for years now
and it all seems as if managing egos is
a big deal me in a film there's a lot of
egos in the NFL managing the egos is a
huge ordeal I don't know if like Levin
Antonio and it's something are too big
of egos to be managed or if there really
is an issue inside of that locker room
on managing the way people kind of their
feelings it's it's something you really
have to do whatever you got those uber
talents and what do you make of the idea
that ven is only doing when you say what
he did on the radio show and Aaron
Rodgers saying that we played piss-poor
every-every elite quarterback
we played piss-poor completely cool cuz
that we talk whenever I think the face
of your franchise which is the
quarterback goes on media in says things
that should be said in either a team
meeting or in a locker room I think that
is just something that you don't really
I don't want to say earn the trust but
it's something like camaraderie is a big
deal in the locker room if you got
somebody who's not willing to say
something face-to-face but then goes on
his local show and says it in Barrie's
like a rookie that you're gonna need
like that's just not a leader like
that's not a leader
we played piss-poor though like I think
that's something that needs to be said
there's obviously some realness in that
but I don't like the singling people out
in the media giving a soundbite making
some cuz you gotta walk back in that
locker room next day what do you when
you walk in there what is it gonna be
it's gonna be like Ogier what I said
about you oh my radio show like that's
just a weird thing then I don't think
any any other elite quarterbacks have
ever done in the past and Ben's numbers
speak for themselves but I think also
what he does off the field is is
something that should be talked about as
well is there an update on the brown
trade he's going at Green Bay
no update John Lynch though one of the
teams Antonio Brown I think would like
to play for the 49ers well I mean Jerry
Rice has said something remember he
Instagram photograph of him in a we're
in the 84 yes John Lynch was asked about
is what he said it's funny the world we
live in where you know one tweet from a
player to another turns into interest
and all of that but hey that
the world we live in I can tell you that
like every team in this league we think
the guy's a heck of a football player
but we have not had talks with the
Steelers I can tell you that for now hey
everything's gonna be smoke screen no is
that right everything's everything you
used to be just with draftable players
right like oh this guy is dumb so we
don't want them and then it's like yeah
we do we're saying that so other people
aren't as interested we leaked that to
the media trying to make other people I
think it's certain happened with free
agents more and more and this is
definitely a case everybody would love
to have Antonio Brown on their team for
the right price sounds like he hasn't
even had a conversation with him what do
you think I don't know if that seems
like a guy that doesn't lie which
doesn't look like a lion which look like
a lion Lynch tomato doesn't so their
quarterback Jimmy Garoppolo Kyle Hannah
Shanahan said on track to participate on
trend organize two team activities
easing back into action holding him out
of 11 on 11
imagine if he zags there instead of six
just a bounce whole new year for an
entirely different year for Hannah and a
different draft pick where they said if
they're low enough they'd be able to
flip that for Antonia brown then are
flipping second overall Fran Tonio brown
no way
no but the top of the second round for
Antonia baby Oh cuz that's it extended
first if you sell it right you love the
extended first we always love extending
so mike Mayock Raiders GM get Derrick
our vote of confidence yesterday Gruden
backed that up today saying he's our
franchise quarterback
let me make that clear that smoke man
something weird was happening out there
though last year yeah the whole week
that the team was judging him for crying
like I don't even know why that would
we're a car right yeah like I don't know
why that would leak if something didn't
happen like something had to have
happened for that to leak I think and
then grew and they lose their bad they
didn't have a stadium next year I mean
that's it's a weird situation never had
a quarterback he liked since Rich Gannon
I think in all honesty Brad Johnson
Reggie I know he did
but I think he finally settled on him
until they he likes the old guys you
know I don't be won the Superbowl with
Brad Johnson but it just he constantly
turns them
well it's cuz he has those 72 word plays
where are they gonna why to spider why
to banana
elephant by the way who stop and go see
later Jackalope hold on a second let me
help you
you cannot denigrate the man whose chair
you're taking in the Monday Night
Football booth I said nothing about
pulling a rabbit out of my head
[Laughter]
I want testing pad I wanna see it okay
how'd you hear about this Mike McCarthy
story a lot of people are gonna want to
see it early yeah Mike McCarthy former
Packers coach involved in an incident of
stepsons high school basketball game on
Wednesday it's being reported he can be
seen on video following the referees out
of the gym and yelling at them went up
the tunnel so according to the Pulaski
high school athletic director oh my god
quote some things were said some
language was used that we don't want in
our gym unsportsmanlike language
officials who worked the game filed a
complaint about the incident I think I
see is that the out River on of Pulaski
Sports is that what you're saying
he's the S school's ad yeah I think we
can all agree here though stepped out of
the year I mean she went out a rough
first step son that's awesome first of
all I think we should talk a little bit
more about that second of all they seek
him to the parking lot they didn't he
didn't I saw the video okay he took like
five steps the refs were being escorted
off to the court right into their locker
room you see a man seems to have a
silhouette of Mike McCarthy she it was a
little blurry all these surveillance
cameras we catch everything that's not
like Bigfoot stuff like you see somebody
in like a gas station do something like
can you find this man see that is a
highlighter blob that you just showed us
right there no we can't find that man
and also we have 720 on our phones at
least do something like that but he just
he took he said something to him the
back ref you see definitely say
something back okay then you see him
like cooked for like a second then he
followed he gives like
five steps towards life step follows
aggressive well then he turns back
around but you got to remember though
they had already separated a little bit
so I think he didn't want to yell out
the unsportsmanlike got closer turns
around comes back when you've got 12
years of being the HC of the Green Bay
Packers you probably have all those Oh
sneaky sneaky comical you can get in
something without you know but he
doesn't have a play sheet to hide his
yeah his lips anymore I just I don't
know I feel like refs don't get yelled
out enough anymore you know I feel like
it's reps just have such an easy life
these days you know like those reps in
the Saints game and the playoffs they
just have the easier hated one more one
more on the social media here so future
Patriots quarterback Josh Rosen
mysteriously had everything Cardinals
related deleted from his Instagram
account josh tweeted out that his
account was hacked
mmm-hmm and that it's all good now he
got it back however Cardinals pics still
missing on the Instagram account would
he throw hammer got it Instagram and
Twitter hacked what do you make of that
Instagram
oh my god I am never one of those types
that looks to the social media to try
and read into what somebody's feelings
are about their professional situation
I'm you should not gonna I think you
should that's like the most intimate
personal times of people have no I I
don't know like so so Steve kind
pronounce him on me on the podium so I'm
gonna go to my Instagram and take all
the cardinal stuff off of it for now in
my freshman dorm now that's a big
statement these days though that is a
huge statement now I will say this
though yes II think smokescreen from
time yes to make that first pic even so
if Rosen can't understand that be an
adult bro the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience